Avengers endgame was a huge turning
point for the MCU but Marvel is far from
finished the question is what arrows are
coming back in the near future
from gods of thunder to green giants
here are the heroes we expect will and
won't appear in phase four in spite of
the trauma that Thor indoors during the
Avengers conflict with Thanos the
Thunder God isn't done with the MCU just
yet at the 2019 comic-con international
in San Diego we learned thor ragnarok
director Tycho ytt is returning to helm
Thor love and thunder currently
scheduled for release in November 2021
ironically while Thor's first two solo
films were some of the least successful
Marvel flicks
love and thunder means that the Odinson
will be the first MCU hero to have poor
starring solo films perhaps the biggest
moment of the announcement was that
Natalie Portman who was nowhere to be
found in Ragnarok would not only
reprised the role of Thor's love
interest Jane Foster but would actually
take on the power of Thor herself her
comic book counterpart replaced the god
of thunder as the all-new Thor for four
years oh we don't know yet exactly how
she'll achieve the same thing on the big
screen while everyone in the real world
was blaming Peter quill for Thanos as
win an infinity war the verse 90 minutes
of endgame saw Avengers like Tony Stark
and Bruce Banner blaming Doctor Strange
the good doctor didn't seem to take it
personally though because he's set to
return for phase four and Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness currently
scheduled to be released in May of 2021
we don't know a lot of specific plot
details yet about the film though some
rumors indicate strange will finally
meet Clea a woman who in the comics
begins as his apprentice and eventually
becomes his wife plus the villain
nightmare ruler of an entire dimension
of bad dreams has been mentioned as a
possible antagonist back in 2019 the
split between Sony and Marvel over
spider-man's appearance in Marvel studio
films had us all worried we wouldn't see
Peter Parker in the MCU again but within
a month they patch things up spider-man
will be free to rejoin his surviving
Avengers in future Marvel films as early
as phase 4 while it wasn't a part of
Marvel's initial phase for lineup
announcement the third spider-man film
is currently slated for release in July
2021 there's little more than
speculation about what's next for Peter
Parker though it's almost certain that
Spidey's identity being revealed by Jay
jonah Jameson
we'll be a major plot point he doesn't
want to be famous
and I'll make him infamous no matter
what else happens in the film Spidey
will definitely have plenty to worry
about but that's usually how it goes for
the old parker luck
well guardians of the galaxy vol 3 won't
hit theaters until 2022 at the earliest
that doesn't mean we'll have to wait
that long to see Marvel's most beloved
spacefaring heroes in March 2020 Groot
actor Vin Diesel let it slip that some
of the guardians would be appearing in
2021 s Thor love and thunder it makes
sense considering how the Thunder God
hitches a ride with the guardians at the
conclusion of endgame though star-lords
crew probably won't play a central role
in that film as for which guardians will
be in love and thunder we're going to
make an educated guess that Gamora won't
appear while star-lord will almost
certainly be hell-bent on finding his
lost love we expect that's a story
writer director James Gunn is going to
want to tell and Guardians volume 3 we
know Ant Man 3 is in the works but we
also know that the earliest we could see
the film in theaters is 2022 which would
put it in Marvel's phase 5 lineup while
we're a little short on specifics most
of the main cast from the previous two
films is expected back including wasp
and her parents the original shrinking
heroes Plus as we all know know ant-man
film would be complete without Michael
Pena's return as Lewis the true star of
the ant-man saga and I was like damn
we'll be you know what you got a chin up
cuz you'll find a new partner
you know what I'm beliefs and he says
you know what I'm Scottie and we're
gonna be best friends yeah hold on one
thing we're hoping to learn from the
upcoming film is the answer to one of
the MC yous biggest unanswered questions
who was Sonny Burch working for an
ant-man in the wasp the crook never
reveals the employer who's desperate to
get their hands on pins quantum realm
tech one intriguing fan theory about
ant-man 3 is that the film will
introduce the Fantastic Four to the MCU
according to the theory the team of
explorers is stuck in the quantum realm
much like Janet Van Dyne was if this
proves to be more than empty speculation
then it could mean birch was working for
the Fantastic Four's arch-nemesis Doctor
Doom will have to wait a few years
before we know for sure though she
sacrificed herself to recover the soul
stone and help defeat Thanos and
adventures end game it's not the last
stop for natasha romanoff aka Black
Widow the former spy turned fallen
Avenger the first of the MCU space 4
films will finally give the heroine her
due
with a starring role in Black Widow set
primarily between the events of Captain
America Civil War and infinity war Anna
fittingly comic-book e twist Black Widow
will be the first solo film released for
a Marvel hero who's already dead unless
she isn't there are a couple of
intriguing theories that suggest that
Tasha might still be alive
one for example proposes that the Hulk's
use of the Infinity Gauntlet and endgame
succeeded in resurrecting not just the
characters we saw in the battle but all
the Fallen heroes including Black Widow
the problem if it did bring her back to
life it would have resurrected her where
she died after falling from that clip on
the distant planet for mirror and who
knows crazier things have happened in
the comics and it's arguable that a few
weirder things have happened in the
movies - based on the Hulk sad claim
that he tried and failed to return the
widow to the land of the living however
the odds are better that she really is
gone for good you know I tried when I
had to go with the stones I really tried
to bring her back
if so Black Widow will be our final
farewell to Scarlett Johansson's iconic
character and our first hello to Yelena
biloba the comics second Black Widow
Valkyrie the no-nonsense Asgardian
warrior Tessa Thompson played to
perfection in Thor Ragnarok is nowhere
to be found for the events of infinity
war she did however return an endgame to
not only join in the battle against
Stannis but to be named the king of new
Asgard and that won't be the last we see
of her
Thompson is confirmed to reprise the
role in 2021 s Thor love and thunder
will also be seen a new side of Valkyrie
Thompson has made it clear the upcoming
film will more openly address Valkyries
canonical bisexuality and that part of
her characters journey in the film will
include finding her Queen Jamie
Alexander who plays SIF in the first two
Thor films but hasn't been seen in any
of the movies since the dark world
volunteered for the job and has the fans
behind her though we don't know yet if
Marvel is taking her up on the offer
considering the events of endgame this
may seem like a no-brainer but don't
expect to see Iron Man back anytime soon
Tony Stark sacrificed himself in the
final battle against Thanos using the
Infinity stones against the villain and
earning a heroic ending to Iron Man
story in the process but for a while now
there have been rumors that Robert
Downey jr. will briefly reprise the role
in a cameo for phase fours Black Widow
on
and as we've learned many times rumors
aren't really worth much until the movie
is in theaters and you know for sure
on the other even the rumors claiming
down he will return make it clear he
won't really return instead archival
footage from a previous film most likely
Civil War will be used as late as
January 2020 Downey has said he has no
plans or interest in returning to the
role of Tony Stark
so while anything is possible in the MCU
don't hold your breath for a phase four
Iron Man return black panther 2 is
coming but surprisingly considering the
first film's massive success it won't be
around in time for phase 4 at Disney's
d23 Expo in August 20 19 mar 11 feet gig
a black panther a release date of May 6
2022 the good news is that even though
we'll have to wait for phase 5 to return
to a Conda it looks like most of the
people who made black panther so
memorable will be back as well I never
yet and as you can see I am not dead
chadwick boseman will return to the
throne as T'Challa
Danai gurira will be back as a co yang
and Leticia Wright will reprise the role
of genius scientist and inventor Sheree
there are even rumors Michael B Jordan
will return as kill longer though
perhaps is a figure of the spiritual
plane rather than a physical villain the
aquatic mutant antihero Namor has been
rumored as a possible bad guy for the
sequel though there's been no
confirmation Avengers endgame concludes
Captain America's story beautifully and
while it's not impossible Chris Evans
could return to the role he doesn't seem
particularly thrilled at the prospect a
spy co-star Scarlett Johansson in
variety's 2019 actors on actors issue
Evans said that if you were to return it
wouldn't be just a cash grab implying he
would want some compelling narrative
reason to continue cap story and reverse
his eagerness to move on to new things
so while it's not entirely out of the
question that we'll see Steve Rogers
fighting evil again one day don't expect
it for phase 4
besides Evans words on the subject
there's no real natural fit for him in
any of pace pores releases the only
obvious option would be the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier but since that series
seems to be partly based on his absence
and Sam Wilson filling his shoes
the new cap having Steve show up to save
the day would be a little weird things
got kind of rough for the Hulk at the
end of endgame as the big guys arm was
horribly scarred by using the Infinity
stones shortly after the film's release
the Russo brothers confirmed that the
damaged Hulk suffers is permanent and it
won't be in a great condition to be
fighting aliens or supervillains any
time soon
however that doesn't mean that that's
the end of the green Goliath in the MCU
in particular there have been
back-and-forth reports that Mark Ruffalo
could be reprising the role of Bruce
Banner in the upcoming Disney Plus
she-hulk series honestly it would be a
little weird if he doesn't show up there
since he's integral to her comic book
origins thanks to a gamma powered blood
transfusion that said Marvel space for
announcement doesn't include she-hulk
so it's likely even if Banner does show
up for his cousin's show it won't be
until phase 5 at the earliest Captain
Marvel was a massive hit so it's a
pretty safe bet there will be a Captain
Marvel - but we're equally sure it won't
be during MCU space for Marvel Studios
has a pretty packed film slate up all
the way through 2021 meaning the
absolute earliest the sequel could show
up would be 2022 which puts it squarely
in phase 5
what's potentially more interesting than
learning when Captain Marvel - will be
released is when it will take place
since the first film was set in the 90s
the option is open to explore the chunk
of time between the first film and
Avengers end game since brie Larson's
hero is away from Earth for most of that
film the second installment could also
look into what she was doing between
leaving our world and returning for the
final battle against Thanos our guess is
that she was beating the living crap out
of evil aliens but we won't really know
until we see it check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you